all right let's hear from a few more
people today we are now taking calls via
discord it typically works really really
well you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go across the pond i hope
i'm pronouncing this correctly is it
chinese in the united kingdom
hi yes it's shanice can you hear me i
can hear you fine are you calling in
from nottingham
i am yes yes what a pleasure in the uk
what a pleasure
um thanks i'm a huge fan of the show um
my question was i was just wondering um
why do you think that the left
kind of uh branding and messaging is
generally so much less successful than
the right i feel as though whenever um
you know the left come up with something
like defund the police or something like
that um it just kind of tends to cause
like a lot of infighting uh it doesn't
really tend to kind of like go as well
whereas when the right come up with
something it always tends to kind of
work a little bit better do you think
it's just kind of i feel as if it's
almost like the bully in the playground
like the wright's voice is just louder
they kind of just go along with points
without really any kind of evidence but
it tends to work better for them than it
does kind of for us on the left
beautiful question so i think that
there's two answers depending on the
circumstances so
sometimes the left just comes up just
brands a bad idea okay so like defund
the police wasn't a good idea it was a
bad idea and as i explained in my
10-point police reform plan
uh reallocation of resources yes reform
replacing police with social workers for
some types of calls yes but in some
places you might need to increase
funding for police in order to
accomplish those things or to be at the
proper level of staffing in order to
have police uh be
uh more proactive than reactive okay so
like defund the police was a bad idea be
as a slogan because the idea itself is
not a good idea that's one side but
there's a whole other set of examples
uh which are sometimes the left assumes
that because we have the right idea
that the branding doesn't matter and we
just have to explain the idea and
everybody will like it and the right who
has the wrong idea is like that doesn't
really matter we just need a slogan and
they come up with a slogan and it works
i mean a pro-life is is a great example
and so is tax relief pro-life well
actually what you're doing is you're
picking and choosing certain medical
situations that should be left to
patients and doctors and assigning a
name to it where if you're against it
it's like wow that your anti-life if
you're not pro-life you're anti-life by
definition that's really good branding
even though the policy makes no sense
tax relief
anytime taxes go down it's the relief of
a burden so even though the real
situation with taxes is you need
well-balanced taxes and well allocated
in order to pay for the things that we
all expect would be paid for through
taxation tax relief listen we're
relieving people of this burden so
sometimes the left is completely correct
on the position and they assume that the
facts alone will win people over and the
right's like no we can just come up with
a better slogan so two different
categories there shanice
that makes perfect sense i really agree
with what you're saying i also think um
i liked what you were saying the other
day as well about um
these kind of uh
politicians who seem to kind of be doing
everything with the coronavirus like
wrong and incorrectly they could kind of
be called like pro-vaccine i think
things like that is like a really good
idea pro-virus you mean pro-virus yeah
virus sorry yeah yeah no definitely i
mean let's call them what they are they
seem to be on the side of the virus and
especially when okay they might refuse
the vaccine but you're also going to
refuse getting tested like what's the
reason that that doesn't make any sense
so yeah these are all uh relevant
examples
okay thank you so much for answering my
questions my pleasure i appreciate the
call
all right shanice from nottingham
uk
uh great great call
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below